it's been a long wait but it looks like
you can finally get your hands on the
division by the end of the month the
game doesn't come out until March but if
you preorder you'll get access to the
closed beta the news comes from a
listing and the you play mobile app
spotted today by wccftech and video game
or websites the text reads take part in
the Tom Clancy's division closed beta in
January 2016 the beta will come to xbox
one playstation 4 and pc but an exact
date has yet to be announced if you want
to get in on the action you can either
pre-order the post-apocalyptic
third-person shooter or you can donate
10 or more dollars to Ubisoft's Humble
Bundle promotion that will also net you
some other tom clancy games such as
rainbow six vegas 2 and splinter cell
conviction the division was announced
back at e3 2013 but it has since been
delayed numerous times fortunately the
wait is almost over tom clancy's the
division launches on march eight for
xbox one playstation 4 and pc if you're
on the fence about the division like i
am i'd recommend dropping the 10 bucks
on the humble bundle that way you'll get
access to the beta you'll get some extra
games and at least some of your money
will be going to charity you can't beat
that for more on the division stay tuned
to gamespot